les gens de la république en marche ont
préféré leur parti à leur pays
[Musique]
non doit pas admirer carlos ghosn pour
son évasion il aurait dû attendre le
verdict de la justice
c'est un délinquant au carré peut-être
il est innocent des premières charges en
tout cas maintenant il est coupable de
s'être soustrait à la justice
donc même s'il était innocent au départ
maintenant il est coupable donc deux
fois non faut pas d'admirer le
coronavirus peut frapper n'importe qui
n'importe quel moment cela dit
statistiquement vraiment c'est pas de
chance de le choper en france il ya
quelques cas sur 66 millions d'habitants
donc on peut l'attraper mais y'a pas de
quoi s'en voit ses 6000 a été ma fille
je lui conseillerais de lire le coran
pour dire un peu moins de conneries sur
la religion musulmane
cependant la première est la grande
priorité c'est de la deûle à protéger de
tous ceux qui lui envoient des menaces
de mort donc voilà si j'étais son père
je la protégerai d'abord et j'essaierai
d'un peu l'instruire ensuite parce que
il me semble qu'elles parlent sans
savoir la benjamin griveaux n'a pas bien
fait de démissionner dans le sens où il
aurait dû résister à la pression mais
comme il était extrêmement mal parti
dans la course à la mairie de paris ça a
été le coup de grâce je pense que s'il
avait été en tête des sondages
il serait resté lors il aurait fait
preuve de résistance face à face à la
meute mais il était déjà trop trop
affaibli mais c'est un très très mauvais
signal de de dire que
dès qu'il y aura un peu de pression sur
un homme politique eh bien il se
couchera il renoncera à toutes ses
ambitions donc ce sera ce sera la loi
des [ __ ] qui l'emportera sur la loi
de la république
[Musique]
agnès buzyn est un choix pour remplacer
benjamin griveaux qui me semble très
très discutable parce qu'elle était en
charge de dossiers très importants
en tant que ministre de la santé donc je
pense qu'en l'occurrence les gens de la
république en marche ont préféré leur
parti à leur pays donc de ce point de
vue là c'est pas un bon choix sinon
c'est une femme estimable le moment
grève a l'air d'être passé mais là on
est passé à autre chose on est passé à
la guérilla législatif puisque les
différentes oppositions ont déposé
plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'amendements dont qu'ils essayent de
rossi de retarder un peu le moment
fatidique mais je pense que la grève ou
la grève en tant que moyen de lutte
contre la réforme des retraites est
arrivé au bout et que voilà il ya de
moins en moins de monde dans l'est dans
les rues et que les gens se sont
résignés maintenant ça s'est déplacé de
la rue à l'assemblée nationale non les
réseaux sociaux sont pas pires que le
terrorisme et le et le réchauffement
climatique mais c'est quand même un
problème parce que nous avons dû ça
comme une grande utopie planétaire tous
les gens autour de la terre ferait
partie de la même famille on pourrait
communiquer avec des gens du bout du
monde des inconnus etc et on s'aperçoit
que c'est pas ça du tout que les réseaux
sociaux sont devenus pour l'essentiel
des robinets à merde et chaque jour bas
le robinet laisse déverser la mer sur
les uns et les autres à chacun chacun
chacun d'ailleurs recevra sa part de
merde des réseaux sociaux donc c'est une
immense déception les réseaux sociaux
parce que ça fait ressortir le pire de
l'humanité alors que vous avez fait
croire que ça ferait ressortir le
meilleur de l'humanité
cela dit chacun d'entre nous peut
utiliser plus ou moins bien ou plus ou
moins mal les réseaux sociaux c'est une
responsabilité individuelle
[Musique]
dont celle de droite alors celle de
droite à tous les sens du terme ça doit
être le rend ça y est oui je m'entends
je m'entends bien avec
je m'entends bien avec laurent ça y est
belle c'est une vraie débutante à la
télévision elle fait une deuxième
carrière et moi je trouve ça très
courageux de repartir à zéro quand on a
atteint un certain niveau dans une
longue confession qui était la sienne
avant qui était porte parole politique
donc oui j'ai de l'amitié et de
l'admiration pour ce qu'elle est c'est
fait
[Musique]